hey everyone hey welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
we are slightly off course from
mainstream programming we are not doing
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons epic this
week we're in fact looking at the the
sequel that the fan fiction that is
Doomsday Clock by Geoff Geoff Johns and
the other guy who's drawing it I forget
his name now Gary Frank there we go Gary
Frank is the guy who's illustrating his
marionettes and such and um yeah me and
death you know alongside doing Watchmen
as a whole are going through this issue
by issue and it's interesting to say the
least I wouldn't say it's some of the
best comic literature I've ever held in
my hands or indeed on a PDF but
nonetheless it's intriguing so we are
going through and as ever it's not just
myself I have my trusty sidekick death
death I do man stir me up stab me up
stubby a band never stop come on how's
it going gang we're just having the
right party everyone's celebrating
because Christmas is over and new year's
on the way come on beautiful that
beautiful interim period any any any
Watchmen gifts death no at all I've got
quite a few comic book things I got a
big Justice League omnibus of the
Darkseid war oh it's not very good it
looks good on the bookshelf in it so you
know when you get ladies ladies coming
round we'll talk about the ladies coming
round later and we'll discuss the the
front cover of this book yeah yeah got
that so yeah good stuff that's new 52 is
it dogs yeah yeah so the last arc where
everything just went [ __ ] mental
yeah Darkseid became a baby and stuff
what yes Batman becomes a god and
Darkseid becomes a baby okay loads are
weird [ __ ] happens in it okay okay well
um yeah I'm sure I'm sure we'll get to
that one day but yeah as I say this is
Watchmen podcast thank you for listening
please subscribe to us on YouTube iTunes
as well you know if you're in a way if
you're listening on YouTube we have the
iTunes feed as well we can catch up on
all the past episodes including our
doomsday one and all the watchman issues
we've done please leave us a review on
iTunes as a greatly appreciate those
pushes up the algorithm and make us more
visible I know the thumbnail is of
like space and for some reason it won't
change but if you download it you'll get
the very cool patented Nathan Jones from
now to shout to that guy it's exclusive
to people who download it I only get to
see the exclusive thumbnail if you
download it yeah it's like an
alternative cover I guess exclusive
exclusive as well watching The Watchmen
pod G monochrome will read out two
emails at the end always get great email
so thank you to everyone this game in
touch as well love the correspondence
let us know what you thought of issues
past or present we love reading them out
we love getting in touch as well I think
that's about it for this and we get to
Doomsday Clock and as always deaf we
talk about covers you know cuz oh my god
the covers two Watchmen they're so
evocative they're so important
they're so that I don't know they tell
such a tale what's your thought on the
doomsday cover which is just sort of
marionettes discarded uniform it reminds
me a bit of my bedroom floor air right
when people come round in the seam oh my
Justice League omnibus are you having
that tied up in that joke before I'm
like I've got a dark side baby yeah I
spent hours writing but yet it's quite a
good cover to be honest I like the nice
leather sort of got a you know there's
them two little red buttons on they they
saw look like a face you know it's kind
of time back to the button it's got the
the red sort of choker is that or is
that like a hair bubble basically it's
sort of in its layout it's very
reminiscent of the yellow button and
it's got even got the red splash on the
side where the comedian's blood was
picture for now it's it's a ribbon mm so
yeah it's he's calling back to that
Stella and I get to be honest yeah I
know we're slagged off the last if you
would seem to be the only people who
didn't like it all I got I got flack off
this one kid who said you can't judge a
book if it's only one issue I said
you're what he's writing loads of
comments and you can't judge yeah oh and
look you can Joe Jimmy it's like saying
you can't judge The Walking Dead
episodes because you've not seen the
full season
you can like something and you can
dislike something mate
I bet a bet if we wrote a glowing review
he wouldn't give a [ __ ] I don't know why
this lad is listening to a podcast
episode called issue 1 review to
complain that we're reviewing one issue
want some hey let's just hey I've read
bloody 300 graphic novels over the past
18 months for my website definition of
Cody okay that's like [ __ ] that's five
graphic novels a week you little
[ __ ] my opinions just as valid as
yours anyway all comments welcome yeah
my comment is free have you have you
seen II I I guess it's the alternate
cover of Lex with the button have you
seen that one yeah that was actually in
the issue head the end of the issue last
time when black and white wasn't it yes
that's right yeah and you've got it got
all the guys his hand on his shoulder I
mean again it's you know it's not that
doesn't happen in the book know where
Batman sitting down reading Rorschach's
journal like mmm yeah yeah yeah I mean
we'll get to those characters in writing
because that is a big theme of this yeah
we've had the promised little crossover
and in this issue we get this to a
certain extent and yeah in terms of the
cover you know I don't mind it I mean
yeah it's sort of interesting it's kind
of I don't know almost like with the two
two buttons it kind of looks like a bit
of a creature doesn't it it looks quite
Turing like I'm not saying it's trying
to appeal to saw the Ozymandias beast
which which they reference in this as
well but yeah it's quite and then we get
the nostalgia as well so Aaron is
everywhere inevitably and um this
podcast is sponsored by nostalgia things
just aren't as good as they used to be
well that's the thing isn't it because
in these opening pages they're talking
about that she says that explicitly yeah
and it's kind of an odd I guess in
John's is being quite weird there
because he's you know this how can a
watchman seek will not be about
nostalgia yeah true true and I like how
they've got the buttons on there on the
dress that constantly love dropping the
button down there that's all ever [ __ ]
I'm surprised I haven't released buttons
with the watchman's face on because God
knows DC are rinsing the [ __ ] with it
I'm surprised they haven't released a
bloody
Rorschach's Journal that you can sit
down and read in your Batcave yeah just
constant just release anything well now
I'm surprised that release watchman
watches yeah I've given him the idea now
don't [ __ ] do it well I think I
mentioned you before and I want to urge
everyone listening to read magic words
by what's his name what only gates
running wrong he's called Ian's parking
but basically yeah Lance parking sorry
and it's a biography of Alan Moore and
it's [ __ ] fantastic like I am the
biggest alum or fanboy
out there I am just twenty eighteen my
resolutions to read all of his works I I
think he's incredible I think he's up
see even the one about the pedophilia
lost girls that's free ordered yeah um
some of those panels are [ __ ] up man
there's one of like Wendy wanking off
Peter Pan and all the Lost Boys Noize
wanking on and yep maybe that one last
but you can have my copy if you want
because I don't think I'll be reading it
God knows if the wife found it if
someone didn't know what it was they
think it was child porn like you discord
in your library so yeah it's pretty
risky but yet that and top ten and
premiere fear and Tom's anyway regard
it's just because you mentioned buttons
before that was one of the things that
piss more off about DC that when
Watchmen was a huge success they started
selling these buttons that were supposed
to be free giving them to comic shops
but they were making profit on them and
Gibbons and more we see no kick back so
is this like a final stab from DC like
here you go mate remember these yeah
I've just realized that Doomsday Clock
its DC in it yeah so yeah D for doomsday
C four o'clock it's wouldn't it's full
matter anyway [ __ ] DC southern buttons
so in everything Watchmen I think I
showed you pictures well one with the
Watchmen film came out there was some
tie-in in some newspaper or something
don't know what the [ __ ] it was but
basically if you sent off this coupon
you got like the watchman button as a
USB with all stuff from the film on it
I've got it in my room on my thing it
could be worth millions
I don't really know so you know anyone
that knows by that gain touch was
watching Watchmen prodigy Mortal Kombat
doomsday 2 begins with as ever as
Watchmen you know more and John's will
always do events going back and forth in
time and you know phrases juxtaposition
there's that word again allusions kind
of playing us out and we learn which is
kind of quite cool actually quite like
this where we learn about the tailor's
wife daddy don't I because I've seen
[ __ ] like this so much in comics whether
like there was this woman who used to
live on the bottom floor called the
prostitute all the superheroes would
come round and have sex with her and
then they did it in a comic in its wendy
was in the next room wanking off Peter
Pan you know I mean it's one of them
staples and comics where they introduced
some new character and she's been doing
it for years and everyone got in there
oh some accountants yeah just one of
them and it's just kind of again not not
to you know wank off more why the Lost
Boys are watching but you know they talk
about the names of the characters doctor
van Gogh telltale man Bill the lizard I
know they're like purposely bad but I
know if Alan Hall was doing this they'll
be kind of cool meta reference later as
these are just kind of what even all
these names are oh yeah and it just
seems strange especially when watchmen
doesn't really have any super villains
in it like know apart from Moloch he's
currently only well yeah he's had
massively retired and yeah I mean they
do confirm in this that costume villains
were got scared the first time that they
did the job and but I suppose you know
it's talking about this reiteration of
costume people coming for which which
sort of speaks to Rorschach and taking
up the well a new Rorschach taking up in
the month all of him and and you just
kind of get this idea that there's
recycled ideas all the time and
especially within the Stiles your bottle
there you sort of it's very much
rehashing the same thing over and over
because people want to live to a certain
standard that they think there was
previously in the same way that Geoff
Johns wants to live to the standard of
Alan Moore and I've just knocked out
no no no no the themes are strong in
this one and I think I think that's fair
play you know we're going back to this
bank and you know this is effectively
being watched why the guys we learn
later in in night hours layer I mean
there's being nice
and then there's being a bank teller
who's willing to lend money to someone
whose accounts overdrawn it's a little
over the top
yeah to relay it be honest this issue is
sort of divided into three sections and
you have this bank robbery bit you have
this Batman bit and that it's two
sections I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about
yeah you sort of have the DC crossover
it's it's very jarring it's no jar and
tonally anaesthetic in dory themes
there's a clear divide between the book
and this entire first half of it just
wasn't with it at all no I just came
like no no no yeah yeah I agree I agree
I really hated pretty much all these
opening pages because you just reminded
of how on more Jonze's like I wish they
gave this to Grant Morrison oh yeah baby
telex someone who's a really intelligent
because to me I don't know I know you
know John's better than me but to me
he's kind of the blockbuster guy like
he's the bigger bent sort of guy and you
know we always have this in Watchmen
someone says something and the panel is
different but it's reference to I can't
get over
AHS even Dyer saying that they the
marionette and you know punch you ever
see the world for a warped lens and we
literally see a warp lens in the piece I
do quite like the nice little divide in
the full panel spread and where you've
got yeah buildings on one side of the
the whole cave and Ozymandias and
Rorschach standing on the other you know
there's a nice little to bite between
them but other than it's sore
it's a bit like like John's is really
good at getting things to the status quo
whenever DC reset the universe like they
did with the new 52 or they did with
rebirth John's always writes the first
story so
hero flash point which was brilliant he
wrote the Justice League first graphic
novel which was brilliant it did the
first one for rebirth he's really good
at like stuff he's like who you would
get if you was starting a new doctor
Doctor Who mhm that's topical that guy's
finger on the pulse rate you know you
see Joss Whedon he's very good at do at
pleasing oh he's JJ Abrams yeah yeah it
started off the Star Wars he got
everything together show that we could
make a great first Star Wars film
and that star was still worked but he
leaned very heavily on things that came
before my house oh yeah and yeah exactly
in sort of returning things at the
status quo and that's what John's is
great at when he's trying to go off with
his own ideas they're not as good
unfortunately no no the guard is reading
black freighter by the way I just know
like I knew his real something cuz I
could see the title but yeah if you zoom
and you can see he's really black very
which which again is kind of a win-win
talking so yeah we have you know I was
watching these tapes back then getting
ready you're getting your hands dirty
again he's literally getting his hands
too like again that's not as bad as the
warp lens one but the water ends one is
it's just like poems in it it's like any
probably imagined the script for this
where Geoff Johns is like in caption
he's getting his hands - no - Gary Frank
draw dirty hands yeah and in that book
this sounds like an advert for lunch
parking but in the magic words but they
have a brilliant Watchmen section all
about his beef with DC the writing in
the book etc and one of the things they
go into is how long Alan Moore scripts
are how unusually long they are and it's
something like each Watchmen issues like
90 pages long and the description of the
first panel he's like three pages long
like it is crazy but here yeah you know
much much more on the nose a really
lacks a subtlety even just little things
piss me off that shouldn't but they do
like on the next page when like because
she's clearly sort of a Harley Quinn
sort of repaid us gem only what I
thought she was going to be when I'm yet
when the
that came out yet see a pale skin a blue
eyes and blonde hair and blonde eyebrows
I thought oh this is gonna be like
Harley Quinn and they're gonna sort of
have their own but with it being an
alternative dimension they're gonna sort
of have their own version of that which
they sort of do but I thought was
literally going to be Harley Quinn yeah
yeah I mean she says happy Monday
someone says it's Wednesday whatever
it's just like yeah I don't know it just
all plays a little bit too much kind of
broadly for me the mime is well kind of
gesturing towards her and this plan it
kind of makes you realize how sort of
silly is that if we find Manhattan we
save the world we'll be heroes again
I mean it's like a microcosm of Awesome
and Alice's ultimate plan of killing
people isn't it it's just misguided you
can see the portholes from a mile away
yeah um and I do you know to the books
credit I do like how we do initially
watch the scene on a security camera and
then we get taken directly into the
action it's got a good tonal shift it's
sort of commented on by ER ism how
removed you are from situations and then
when you're living in the moment you
know reading this the first time I did
sort of think of it oh this is this is
gonna get like really graphic and
violent all of a sudden and it's start
worrying for these characters and in the
bank but it doesn't really go up with
that place and unfortunately and it's
it's very kind of mundane like he's just
robbing the bank with his finger I mean
I mean the art is really good Gary
Franklin's absolutely and it did an
absolutely outstanding Superman story
where it's basically it's got the
Christopher Reeve look to Superman but
it's really really good art and
everything like the guy does is really
well thought out well done but it sort
of loses the tweeners of Gibbons work
and there was a nice sort of I don't
know like cartoonish feeling to Gibbons
his work that when it was doing all the
graphic violence it kind was like wow
was like you know Bugs Bunny but next
level um it had like a nice related
relatable aspect to or that you could
sort of harken back to your childhood
with and think I remember reading be no
comics and stuff like that you had very
similar drawings and it was elevating
that feeling for you and I made it just
made a world of difference in those
books where's this mm it's well drawn
but it just doesn't have that
personality that Gibbons has had totally
agree yeah yeah there isn't that soul
behind the faces like some of them a
good like I like the section on the next
page where he puts against the glass and
then smashes head through it's quite
kinetic I like the use of the paneling
adjacent to each other
I see watchman has trained me similar to
like when you watch loss to investigate
everything I'm just looking at the panel
now when he breaks through the glass as
a picture and the woman's saying ah but
it just looks like a fish or something
it's like you look like a Yank I thought
is gonna be something that like reveal
the plot but you know it's not it's not
really any well maybe maybe issue 12 you
know that it's gonna be some massive
fish oh it's it's gonna end like that
isn't it I just know that doomsday
clocks gonna end of a massive monster he
has to yeah you know we're slugging
Frank off but when he gets to the DC
stuff
I think his he fits that better like
Bruce Wayne stuff but I think it's
absolutely brilliant I think it's Lex
Luthor stuffs incredible and and he fits
that aesthetic a lot better than this I
kind of think it's almost too realistic
for Watchmen sure I would have rather
had like a bit more of a cartoonish draw
draw I [ __ ] it's off reading this
Congress trations by a more cartoonish
artist yeah yeah cuz this is just so of
do it too realistic and it takes away
the dark comedic edge that watchman had
mm-hmm and I mean we learn later that
they're on a spree they killed a lot of
people before this as well so you do
wonder where the police are but whatever
the alarms been raised they go to the
cache
they grab the caches sons picture who's
holding Ozymandias doll which I mean
yeah it's I guess you've got to get your
references to the world in somewhere
there's a nostalgia perfume in a bag
it's it's just a little unnecessary it's
like we know we're reading a watchman
comic we don't need to have all these
signposts yeah and it's very cliche it's
strange that once again they've decided
to use the holding neck kid hostage
monkey like the first issue brasha got
what are their names as a marionette and
mine yes that's what I keep forgetting
the names as well that yeah they started
they basically lured marionette out
because they used her kid as a hostage
and it's the same thing again it's yeah
yeah a very basic thing used to drive
characters like more would have found a
much more creative way to threaten a
bank teller totally and you would have
like you know shook of the stock market
or something it's it's strange that the
the most interesting character in this
entire book I think is the bank manager
yeah it's actually more evil than the
villains he's definitely the most
interested in this bank robbery he uses
words like [ __ ] you know an e isn't PC
anymore more is back more it's back get
his finger cut off which stops um using
the security law Akkad is very it's just
a night he's a nice character he's very
fleshed out in very little you sort of
get that he's an [ __ ] party's more
about worried about the money than he is
his staff he [ __ ] caused the cut
years sooner [ __ ] he says and you're a
bore to look at so it's also said Inez
and you're ugly by the way yeah he's the
best character in their booth I want to
see a spin-off with just him yeah
written by Jeff Jones
oh no it's it's not it's not gonna be
good so yeah and then we get some hyper
violence and we get sort of the first
bit of action really in the next panels
where she does a gamble in the air for
some reason slices off his finger quite
artistically it's kind of cool that his
finger sort of hanging there
and the cuts been made it's guess what
your thoughts on the attack I didn't I
didn't really get the whole thing just
starts like she's tumbling through the
air and that's a bit and then she comes
down and yeah it's it's it is it's like
good it sticks in your mind it does it
does and there's a bit of dark more like
humor that the thing she cuts off is
what they need to unlock the safe and
yeah just kind of and then we get dr.
Manhattan arriving which is quite
exciting you know obviously he's arrival
is a direct register this return he's
returned because handy he hadn't left of
I'm trying to think where this plays
into no no this is way before the end
this is way before Watchmen and I think
so
the I mean it's his return of the story
you know I mean I would say Luke
Skywalker he's back the lad is back but
this is before the can see a conspiracy
yeah yeah yeah so this is just about
this is when he was out superhero and
beetle job yeah yeah well I mean they do
say actually he just say you messed with
the wrong Bank actually so maybe dr. hat
I mean we've seen dr. Manhattan has
multiple dr. Manhattan so arguably
perhaps this is just the alarms go off
and he just splits into another person I
don't know I think it's a bit too small
scale for dr. Manhattan yeah oh nice
yeah he was off stopping he was solving
[ __ ] energy crisis and stuff hmm now
he's stopping bank robberies well the
Vietnam War - [ __ ] TSB like it doesn't
really make any sense and but he's and I
just hated the fact she says wow nice
briefs it just robs the moment of any
poetic brilliance it's just and I know
that's who she is but it just undermined
it for me do you think we'll get a
doctor Manhattan dick I don't think so I
don't think we'll you know I think
John's is like that I'm not doing it
lads I'm trying to sell these books to
kids mm-hmm that's why fingers are
getting sliced off yeah yeah yeah again
there's some quite gruesome I she would
the bank manager the tears running from
I was looking at the stump of his finger
but I mean you get the feeling the dr.
Manhattan could just click his fingers
and the fingers back on like yeah why
did he arrive here then he could have
arrived here five minutes before
I mean he knew this was gonna happen
yeah you know it's too small scale for
this is like Rorschach level yeah yeah
it is it is and he arrives and mime
faces off of him I mean we've discussed
in the press I don't know see this fight
just to see the lad get completely torn
just visually I mean they don't quite
know it's it's weird innit and then he's
going to kill my he doesn't have the
power I know on the page no I agree the
instrument quite holy and sacred about
doctrine he looks a bit even though late
his expression and watch in his
expressionless and he's in in these
expressionless and this as well but it's
not as expressionless no so it's not as
good okay okay what the lads I mean
something on the level of you know
Batman vs Superman Martha liked him not
destroyed look she's killed 47 people so
why can't he way up the mathematics and
just be like and this is the person who
said like humans you know alive or dead
it's the same atoms cause you can see
she's got a baby yeah yeah but but what
is that matter to him IIIi would have
think he's quite in human by this point
but maybe it's before he really breaks
away after you know the Wally Weaver
stuff yeah but I don't get why I
couldn't just kill my many weigh like
her standing in front of mine means
fuck-all it's just like he just needs to
click and he's dead so yes like he needs
to pass through stuff his energy waves
it just feels like you literally do
nothing here already killed a lot turn
around
they've expended so much death already I
don't know why he cares and I was when I
first read this for some reason I didn't
realize it was the heartbeat and I
thought baboom was like this like
character in the world it was I love the
paper use called paper yeah
Baddeley told the panelings all over the
place it doesn't make it very clear it's
gonna name me kid after that because I'm
such a huge DC firm and we see these
kids I mean this kid better turn out to
be important I'm sure it will it'll be
fun Rorschach is about I know what the
[ __ ] is gonna be but yeah and this is
the reason apparently that [ __ ]
Osmond dies wants to get them involved I
thought there was gonna be a great
reveal maybe there's more for us to know
yeah but if this is the reason that John
had a twist of fate John change his mind
I'm sure he did this to quite a few
people I'm sure he wasn't just like you
know despot that was killing criminals
I'm sure he had a heart cuz you know
obviously had the the toys too I'm Sally
and he had a sort of human relationship
and stuff like that so it's just
is this why they're using them because
John decided not to kill them after they
killed loads of people like yeah well
like they kind of allude to the fact
that this is these are two people like
John's gonna remember it's gonna make
him wanna pretend her earth but he could
have chosen better characters in these
shows like the the fact he's got someone
dressed of his Rorschach that's like
enough for him to water return Shirley
mmm I mean maybe that is why he's got
someone dressed up as Rorschach because
he's like oh look it's all the people
you knew when you were on earth they're
back but you know it's just but this is
probably gonna be the only time that we
see dr. Manhattan but boys big reveal in
the present yeah and it's just a very
bomb no it just feels like a cameo like
yak I don't see why they need to get him
back like why this is so important just
know bit of a mess yeah yeah and it's
just so tenuous like we're talking about
and and you know Rorschach says you
could have got some other people should
have got Laurie and Osmond over seeing
her we Dan could upset him well we know
it won't because he didn't care or Mars
so what he care now didn't give a [ __ ]
he smiled he actually smiled and he seen
the big enemy Watchmen well it's quite a
big plot point that he doesn't care I
just don't yeah it's quite frustrating
death
when he's leaving Earth he goes and sees
him doesn't he yes
together on that bed and in that
tiger-skin or whatever and he gives a
little cheeky smile like give her one
for me and so yeah I don't I don't see
why okay I suppose Ozymandias wouldn't
know that but yeah I get a guess I guess
so but I mean the reader does so it
doesn't matter because it getting the
[ __ ] marionette in the mine
that's not Plan B these are gonna be the
stickler for me if these are in the
whole series which of course they're
going to be yeah this is not listenable
e they just like go metal at the end and
[ __ ] up the whole plan in like murder
everyone yeah yeah right
my baby so Archimedes Archie takes off
and then we get to the next page where
they all sort of jump in the owl and we
learn a bit more about you know what we
already know that the world is in kind
of you know a horrible uproar and I mean
kind of interesting in a way that they
can find dr. Manhattan the the blue is
like the electrons leaking from the body
to the trail I mean what do you think
about that well it talks about was
intrinsic field again which if you go
back and listen our episode of dr.
Manhattan's origin I said it's a bloody
intrinsic field is what his power is
that he can manipulate and [ __ ] and
everyone laughs that is the world slug
in his are Eric Ferguson he was sitting
there going this guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but yeah got mentioned here
again I'm sure Eric didn't say that he's
a good man but we have four questionable
people in Archie the the nukes of you
know I've been fired
so it's tense kind of awesome Windows
has adopted my hat and button the Basie
allows him to do this quantum tunneling
to go yeah so go back right I didn't
know I thought that explosion was like
them on the ship it's not got blasted
the other dimension yeah again the
missile just comes out in a way and it's
not clear when the missile is fired if
it's there more the missile so it's like
it's a bit yeah again there's a lot of
issues just minor issues with the
paneling
but is that a nuclear bomb hidden so
because azam and i says in the previous
thing are the four hour for four hours
up are the nukes in the air so that was
kind of their time before it but it's
just this is what I you know this is
what I don't like about it I think
Watchmen you know we have done long
episodes and issues of Watchmen and it's
watertight it holds up to the scrutiny
you can really enjoy yourself this it
just has too many lapses for me too many
ruts in the road but yeah we go through
and again death it's quite a nice homage
isn't it seeing their skeletons
fragmented which brings back images of
dr. Manhattan of Bubastis
from issues of old yeah it's a nice
little touch am I just to know what the
hell is going on no where's this button
come from that they can use to travel
through dimensions base but I mean with
yet they watch amazing dad when you were
mechanics every every [ __ ] night on
Friday and talk to some old guy if he
had this button in his [ __ ] thing do
you not think he'd be off Swan enough to
the seventies by reading Hana I really
hope you know that 70s the best bloody
decade of all time if we're playing with
timelines I would love for them to go
back to 13 oil and they mention that
start this issue when the Minuteman are
in their heyday that would be cool Jesse
you know if we're gonna play with
timelines let's go back into watching
this on med bottle [ __ ] John's as
[ __ ] up as well so so yet they they
get Visser aid back in time and kidnap
the black lad from who was reading black
freighter make him Rorschach just go
slowly do it again again
Rorschach's identity is still a mystery
at this point they go forward you know
he pushes his spot they give him a name
though they yeah they do they call him
Reggie so instantly I googled Reggie
Watchmen and but it just came up some
baseball card lesson for for card some
American football card where a black guy
was running on the front of it and I
just had Watchmen written behind him so
yeah I mean I don't I don't mind the art
here of them going forward in this world
and all of this writing and then
Rorschach's face or Reggie's face
becoming the inkblot now death you know
we all know on the show that you are mr.
Batman
you know you adore Batman you're Batman
knowledge is unparalleled your fandom is
unquestionable why your forwards on the
first appearance of mr. Wayne here
I went [ __ ] mental yeah I went
complete I went Wow
it I was a it's worth it it's the best
book of all time I do like how they soft
either universes together like when
Archie's flying through the sky and one
of the the pedestrians say is it a plane
sure is a massive Superman motif so it's
subtly tying the two universes together
and Rorschach
I've said it 400 times we're gonna be
401 after this Rorschach and Batman are
very similar so it's nice that these two
characters are sort of in it twine to
throughout this issue from this point
you start with that where Bruce Wayne
having a Rorschach test knit it's very
similar to the Rorschach origin story
issue that we've just done you over
watching The Watchmen podcast the
podcasts that you're now listening to
come on like in comments subscribe don't
comment if it's a negative comment just
write nice things like I love this these
are great definitions great and so yeah
completely [ __ ] myself and this happened
and it's just nice that Batman he's
doing the play boy persona still he
story all he's ever seen as a yacht and
I quite like how the last one it does
look a bit like a bat yeah but he
doesn't even say that which the the
psychiatrist probably this guy's [ __ ]
mental because this looks like a bat and
he lives in Gotham which is home a
Batman surely everyone would say that
yeah yeah yeah we just talked about
speedboats and [ __ ] yeah you all right
yeah I mean obviously I consider the
parallels but didn't consider that we we
meet Bruce through Malcolm obvious it's
not Malcolm long but through a therapist
our origin yes recently so yeah this
time together in a nice wide why don't
the meet through malcolm is it because
he's off being Rorschach I'm gonna I'm
gonna fry them I even though he schooled
Malcolm not Reggie I think in some in
some places Malcolm sure for Reggie so
it's the Sun it's the [ __ ] Sun the
Sun they did have children I see because
he has the dad mug doesn't he
yeah it's the Sun yeah yeah they found
his dad's notes and he went off on one
so we you know we get to meet Lucius now
which is quite cool and I should say as
well which I didn't quite realize and I
needed to read the interview Geoff Johns
to appreciate it's come not like a DC
head I'm just reading doomsday just two
Watchmen fan this is taking place now
where we are in Gotham a year in front
of where the current universe is isn't
it is it it is I don't know yeah it is
so we've got this joint loop so
basically where we call a I read Batman
every week so where we are now is kind
of you know this is explaining the liner
notes at the end but there's some soft
mesh human controversy that's going to
explain a little bit later and yeah
basically Bruce and douches are talking
and I had like what the Mad Hatter and
the twins are on the loose as a Batman
fighter who the twins I don't know the
twins it's a bit like my namesake and so
my name is Paul Tweddle
the twins are Tweedledee and Tweedledum
from the famous story Alice in
Wonderland so he has these hats that you
put some people it's mind control you
know yeah and yeah I've never did it's a
massive thing on my website where I just
went on a run slugging him off in the
middle of a review got quite a lot of
hate from it but it's just a plagiarist
character and me like you know mad has
already occurred exactly who greenlit
this and come up with it and pretty much
every story that I've read with him was
absolutely [ __ ] terrible over you
know however all over the 30 years have
been alive I'd never read a story with
him that I enjoyed until Scott Snyder
did this one and where he sort of felt
as the work he created this thing that
felt as the world and skins it is you
want to see it you know how snapchat and
that's gonna bounce we're slowly losing
our identities because people are
sticking dog ears on everything great
issue in which Bruce Wayne confronts the
Mad Hatter Mad Hatter's like look you
love
[ __ ] you you think you're Batman
you're not you you're some [ __ ]
paralyzed kid and all I've done is give
you this fill out that makes you think
you're Batman but people you know you
only meant where the fella for an hour
because you know can have adverse
effects where people lose their grip on
reality and stuff and you've been you've
been living this lie that you're Batman
I'm actually here to help you and all
you all your villains are psychiatrists
and stuff your anonymous eylem your
[ __ ] mental mate and I was reading it
going Jesus Christ this is the best
thing that they've ever done with a
villain ever
I started [ __ ] meself I started
thinking what if I am mental umm and I
started like counter guessing all the
Batman 75 year history and stuff and it
was a really good use of the character
that also commented on society at the
moment I don't want to spoil the ending
and but definitely check out all-star
Batman vol 2 that has that saurian um
but yeah other than that the lads
[ __ ] [ __ ] as a villain big up Scott
Snyder by the way yeah I listened to him
on fat man on Batman have you listened
to that Kevin Smith's Batman podcast
Batman never heard of it what's it about
III false cause I didn't really heard
like him speak before enough what he
came off really well and I think he is a
really good comic book writer but yeah
I'm you listen and Grant Morrison once
Grant Morrison ones are amazing yeah
he's Killing Joke stuff and he's
explanation to ending a meteoroid yeah
it's absolutely brilliant it's just kind
of think it's a shame that fat man and
Batman sort of diverted from that yeah
format now yeah it's more like a TV show
now and he doesn't really get I mean
Mark Bernardin's great on it and but
it's sort of divert it from its original
formula and I do kind of wish that Kevin
Smith would go back and interview these
people again and because I mean it could
definitely get some big he had Paul Dini
on it cut the time in those episodes are
brilliant I mean you guys had Danny
O'Neill and and that but right bro I've
never I've never heard of it what is it
Tom what is that podcast it's it's a
rival to us in a sir
why so I'm not gonna give you any more
airtime but yeah we get a lot of
exposition here if you actually look at
the paneling of lucious and Bruce
there's so much text on this on the page
explain a lot so you know they talk
about Lex Corp and and and you know
Wayne Enterprises blah blah and the
meta-gene which Superman theory it
mentions it's kind of a cliche isn't it
in superhero comics that the public hate
the superheroes when we'll cuz we we've
had Watchmen that's the ultimate
vigilante you know Accountancy story
yeah I do quite like it though um I do
I much prefer Batman when he's against
the police and the public
I don't like when he's like there's this
public figure walking down the street
like shaking people's hands and stuff
like he was in the 66 shot oh I always
like you know yet my perfect Batman is
he's 30 years old very handsome man he's
in his first couple years of it the
supervillains are just starting to
arrive there's a war going on between
them and the gangsters the public most
people don't believe he actually exists
most the police don't believe he
actually exists and they sort of trying
to always catch him in there they're
glad that he's helping but they also
want the publicity from bringing him
down
I don't like it went Batman's like a big
staple of Gotham and everyone knows
about Claude so it's nice I do
appreciate that they turned him into a
villain almost you know he's in honey
here oh yeah yeah and I think this as I
say is in the future so the Batman
comics the rebirth comics the moment
it's this young happening is it they
don't hate Batman no no at all he's
pretty much it's in backyard mode at the
moment which is where he's always one
he's always able I don't think everyone
to take them down and that's sort of you
know Scott's grandma isn't basically
made bat guard which is where Batman was
always like the best member of the
Justice League
he was always tactically far superior to
everyone else and then Scott Snyder sort
of brought him down made him very
vulnerable I
there's some at the core of owls Batman
just gets absolute [ __ ] kicked out of
them and this points where he's crawling
through this maze and he's go and mental
he's like early thought like it's barely
holding his costume together and
rebirths sort of went back to the back
guard our teeth where he's he's very
calculated he's always one step ahead of
everyone he's a full Tax Act ition he's
able to take on like millions of people
and bring them all down and so it seems
like they've gone this sort of way with
that where they're building it up to
Batman so good that the police are now
going against him and because of that
the public are - they mentioned wreck of
Rex Mason and Kirk Langstrom as well and
Rex Mason is a character called
Metamorpho which he's sort of like a
hulking figure his power as they can
make any element he's a good guy he's
you know it's been a member of the
Justice League and he's sort of very 70s
based he's one of those Silver Age
characters Kirk Langstrom is man-bat
Ryan which is obviously like a massive
hulking bat that haunts Gotham and he's
a great character absolutely like the my
favorite Batman animated series episode
is the first one which focuses on
man-bat and they dude it's called on
leather wings so definitely check that
out it's a free on Amazon Prime yeah
yeah Scott's annoyed to mention actually
in families yeah when I'm not seen it he
said it was one of his favorites as well
yes absolutely brilliant and just like
the way the animation is the score it's
really well put together and my dad was
always kind of a goofy character but
that makes him believable he's sort of
like a Jekyll and Hyde sort of thing and
so it's nice that they mentioned very
early on these niche characters like
Tweedledee and Tweedledum wrench Mason
and man that yeah and we I mean again we
had some nice illusions here got us out
quite like the sequence where the
bat-signal when the eyes come in yeah I
really like that fruit yeah I think
that's very very nice I wish they'd
started the book off like this you just
Bruce Wayne getting a Rorschach test he
steps outside the bat signals out there
to map survives beam through boom right
wait wait out that's a way better way to
start a makes the world together and
then you can fill in about the the riots
back home and why they've traveled to
this earth in the space of like a page
and I know it's this only because I mean
we're doing Killing Joke very soon
actually I think Killing Joke be next
when we do and I've bought it I've never
actually owned are bought yesterday on
my water stones gift card
thank you to my dear brother first I got
mine from water stones as well that's
really good so I remember always he's
going in it's the only ever book like a
port from what stones I think what
graphic novel anyway and they always
have it on the shelves like oh yeah
pointing at you like everywhere you
can't cook and turn around without being
there so I know it's because I just read
Killing Joke yesterday the where Archie
crashes is clearly the fairground of
Killing Joke right yeah yeah I mean yeah
which is which is interesting you know
again it's yeah we're in DC world now
a Martian were again it is it is yes
exactly exactly yeah and we're here and
they've survived and I quite like
Rorschach not being conscious and then
the sign that he's alive is that the ink
blots start to move yeah yeah this is
where the book really picks up and they
should honestly they should have just
started with this yeah um but yeah they
land in the fairground with the elephant
and that very Killing Joke they also by
doing this confirm that the mime isn't
the Joker yeah a lot of theories were
gonna bow that now there's three Joker's
in the DC Universe and a lot of theories
were gone about that this was one of the
Joker's but in doing so with this
timeline he can't be and again they
mentioned that Rorschach's name's Reggie
no idea that is it's his son
it could be son it could be a son we
were here in this world he's angry
they've made it I mean I was him and I
stood there going off him and Rorschach
the fine quote-unquote the smartest man
in this world
does he really think that handcuffs are
gonna stop them
really yeah
I don't mean he's teaming me he's the
smartest man in the world earning scope
in a box or maybe his plan was to make
it look like you was locking them up to
Rorschach so Rorschach would go along
with them but you knew that escape yeah
yeah yeah I mean yeah and maybe maybe
Walter Kovacs would have known their
escape but Reggie might not be his
experience there Reggie we we get that
we get I want to say Bubastis Bonita
have a word with my mate actually cuz
his name is Rajeev I've just remembered
his email address is Reggie 2k13 at
hotmail.com so you never know the lad
could actually be Rorschach so fan
theories fast who's up for done read it
up for it
do you because because we get
expressions that the cat is very
important she's more than a pet he says
she's the compass so I mean this is me
thinking here that it is Bubastis who
intrinsic field was pulled apart as we
saw in the last issue and now it's now
it can see intrinsic fields I guess and
can leave them there all I like how they
neither explain that but they don't
explain why they've just got a button
that shifts dimensions they what they
should have done is they should have
explained the dimension shift and then
just had a button on Archie that could
track dr. Manhattan by Owen and we were
in the team The Watchmen we all had like
these implants put in us or something
that allows us to be tracked by Archie
if we're ever in danger they were gonna
use that you know I mean don't [ __ ]
bring Bubastis into this don't bring the
lad anyway yeah it's just a cell action
figures like plush toys of Bubastis like
then porks in Star Wars oh yeah I mean
they what they've just a quick tangent
they weren't as bad as I for I opponent
really like last Jedi but they want they
want all over the place were they they
want like the minions or something no
they weren't bad um yeah they I thought
it'd just be like a character they were
just background noise I'm a ring Gotham
oh you know we're appreciating the
difference here isn't watching The
Watchmen graffiti but there is a
you know crossed out it's like PG go
griffie you know whenever you watch a PG
movie in this always like graffiti and
like seeds and stuff in the background
they always have like I still I rap is
cool and police are bad it's very PG
Griffith graffiti keep an eye out for it
in movies it's quite funny and they
passed some movies
Nathaniel dusk and you I didn't get any
of these references they went over my
head is this some DC thing or no I'm
Nathaniel dusk
I googled them he's a real movie
character okay it's like fictional
detective from the forties come a
Coleman though didn't get anything when
I googled him so I'm not too sure what
that is they kind of hang on that moment
quite a bit as well they do yeah I
actually read that panel a couple of
times to see if I was missing something
but yeah they say he's deaf remains one
of Hollywood's most brutal unsolved
murders I guess a comedian allusion I
don't know and then they mentioned
Hemingway Wolfe and my offs Mayakovsky
who they do say what are they got in
common and I did work this out because I
didn't realize just from my you know
very very useful English history degree
there all three of these commits suicide
so I don't know if that's some sort of
but I still don't know what that really
means but yeah here we are
Gotham City Public Library and again I
do want to praise the art I think I
think the art looks pretty cool here I
love the long panel yeah that page you
just get really the gothic feel of this
sorry but there's nothing worse than
like you know in movies when you get
like the front page of newspapers and it
tells you the plot and it sort of keeps
you going yeah it's quite lame to see
Ozymandias and [ __ ] Rorschach on a
computer in an odd way it's like didn't
they already know these things I know
they go into a different dimension and
maybe they don't know who's smart
whatever whatever
what are you Google though smartest man
in the world I don't know what he's
gonna find why did it feel like they
need to yeah why not just go for google
the smartest man in the world and then
both go to him I just I guess it's smart
using this place maybe
powerful like if you nail in game they
probably find out Bill Gates or whatever
but it's still you know it's quite lucky
to the landed in Gotham but you know
they knew there and actually if you look
at the lex lives in Metropolis anyway so
that's true yeah they are they close to
each other they lock in New York Chicago
or depends yeah I got what version like
the DC movie stuff Gotham and metropolis
are just across the harbor but nothing
else I don't think has them that close
in proximity no no well I mean they they
find out the men Lex and Bruce and then
they basically split up and we get quite
a nice section here again I'm not doing
great i but it's fine
Rorschach going into Wayne Manor yeah
you know what never really occurred to
me and awesome and Isis is sort of a
cross between Lex Luthor and Bruce Wayne
like he's a crime fighter but it's also
a super villain he's a billionaire you
know he's he sort of the the in-between
of them which here never really occurred
to me till reading this book that he's
sort of a bassist and he works as both
what would happen if they both went
mental
Oh Lex Luthor was to win or something
and Wayne Manor like that did he just
show up there I think I've got a feeling
that Wayne Manor is very [ __ ] secure
yeah mainly from the fact that once the
police broke in well didn't break in
they they believe that Bruce Wayne was
Batman so they went to arrest him and
there's actually they found that
entrance to the Batcave right and uh you
reading it thinking [ __ ] hell that how
can they get out of this anyway the
there's a security thing in the entrance
to the Batcave that if you're not Batman
or Alfred
it's another staircase opens up instead
of the main one that just goes down it
like a basement like man cave were like
TV in like comic books in like dartboard
and stuff so it's pretty [ __ ] secure
I don't think you could just climb in
the window yeah feel a breeze underneath
a grandfather clock it's [ __ ] world's
greatest detective it's like come on it
is bad it is bad the clock only opens if
it sent you a certain time which is the
time that his parents died so he
wouldn't be able to just young it open
I'm pretty sure it's magnetized yeah and
the pancakes so to me that the card says
good morning Bruce so he's that good
morning Bruce from Alfred or is it Ian
good morning
I know Alfred Alfred sort of makes them
short for when she comes in your hair on
the night light Alfred's always got a
meal ready for them in the morning
that's a nice little touch it's nice
that he just finds that and starts
eating it yeah yeah but I man probably
would have liked door of every eventual
outcome though and those pancakes would
be poisoned sure sure you can sort of
see a smiley face on the plate you can
see two eyes inis yeah I mean Reds I
mean obviously the syrup kind of looks
like blood I mean again you saw see the
shadow of Rorschach behind Reggie as
he's here which again is kind of I mean
we've had this a billion times the true
identities of silhouette you know it's
just a bit sort of he gets in the
Batcave somehow he I should say the
doctor he literally does and and he just
so he finds out there's a breeze from a
match which again is just kind of meh
we've seen this before but the Ganga
diner I should say which is again you
know we're in the watchman water we're
not were not in watch more and he won't
be saying this ahead he goes down
through the thing and Batman's alerted
for a little alarm that you know
someone's gone in there and then we get
to Lex and what do you think about the
sign of LexCorp labs we're go missing is
screwed over be prosecuted yeah I quite
liked it that is Lex isn't it he's kind
of quite noxious Lee brilliant I guess
they keep talking about this corporate
takeover don't they the relaxed Corp
they should call it a Lex corporate
takeover nice having that
yeah so yeah we're in his office now
he's so I don't know what he's working
on but he walks out firing everyone and
they seem to be going mental in the
background I don't know what they're
doing
he throws his gloves into like some
toxic waste shoot em he says Oh use
human diet ice what what you doing here
well then got an angel pick you're on
the wall which it's giving his bad
flashbacks to Batman V Superman yeah
when Lex Luthor has used a [ __ ]
stupid angel oh yeah of course talks
about that the end the movie on the
means nothing
yeah and he just he doesn't seem that
bothered he's just like oh I'll get
security to show you out you have three
minutes to talk your plan while I wait
for security I know yeah I don't I don't
really like it I mean it's quiet it's
cool that they meet don't get me wrong I
think I think it's very cool yeah and
you know having read all star Superman
recently where Lex is a really good
character a really interesting character
I was kind of endeared towards him we go
back to the tooth two most hated people
in this [ __ ] universe he's bursting
still alive yeah yeah do you have your
lockpick and they look straight at the
readers you know maybe as if it's a this
is lame we know but we're gonna get out
there's no rules here sort of thing and
they're talking and Lex's office is
quite similar to you know Voight's
office as well but I mean it's a prison
or a book but Lex I quite like it you
know he realizes very very quickly what
the [ __ ] was your plan like what'd ya do
shits are more a bit Danny yeah like
just sort of reiterate the plan from the
end of Watchmen with the whole alien
invasion uniting the world and he's just
saying if you're the smartest man on
your planet I'd hate to meet the dumbest
which made is a bit angry because he's
sort of calling more a bit dumb there
anymore call me a [ __ ] earlier I'm
[ __ ] Carla bastard pull my finger more
more more how do you like it [ __ ] Geoff
Johns I'll use him on the John when I
went to the John I had a shite you see
hey see you later
I was just Ellen will pop
say yeah so he's soul [ __ ] on the
entire watchman butanol night welcome
hell you thought it was good enough to
write a new one about you naked and this
is not bad they're meeting I do like
Rorschach going to the Batcave and
thinking quite logically that this you
know must be a villain not a hero
because of yeah cause of all the
trophies ya know it's nice and it's got
like nice little it's got the flashbacks
of the costumes and stuff what is that
yellow costume who's got no idea mate
you can't leave I was really hoping you
weren't gonna ask you that because I've
just shown meself up on the show there's
some nice stuff there's like the dice
and stuff like like it reminds me of the
fortress of solitude in all-star
Superman when you see a really cool
stuff and got penguin umbrellas there
yeah the Daleks like when did Batman
fight a dinosaur it's just a staple of
the Batcave that's a giant penny in
there and there's a giant t-rex
yeah always there and we sort of learn a
bit about Joker kills 18 nurses 19 3 are
dead 50 [ __ ] me man what an [ __ ] so
yeah he's killed his but we get to see
the cool Batman cost you as well on the
Robin as well and a gun for some reason
that he's in there for and now we get to
prolly goodness is the gun that shows
parents oh yeah yeah and now we get to
you know quite surprising I was reading
this was like okay this is kind of
interesting so they're talking blah blah
blah this is this is Ozzie and Lex
gunfire Lex gets shot and comedians back
yeah no idea but I mean the guy is human
dies to say impossible yeah um yeah no
idea I don't know how they're gonna
explain it it's all makes all of
watchmen pointless because the entire
book was predicated on the comedian's
death but you know people never stay
dead in comic books
unless that Uncle Ben or I was gonna say
unless they all been all the Wayne's put
the bra
the [ __ ] Wayne's back didn't there so
yeah unless your Uncle Ben you don't
stay dead yeah I mean that's all we
really you know we just this time I'm
ready for you chameleon says but that's
interesting this time I'm ready for you
so he has awareness of the other world
that he's been in so I mean the only
explanation really is a dr. Manhattan
resurrected him there's no yeah there's
no of a real explanation yeah maybe he's
like dr. Manhattan projection that and
he's saying this time I'm ready for you
is like the words of dr. Manhattan yeah
but I don't worry don't know and then
we've got a flashback to the Rorschach
test randomly yeah which is a base and
and then yeah it's a ban and a Rorschach
finally me yeah and quite like it's a
giant penny for giant penny there is a
giant penny which is just kind of I mean
Lincoln's looking towards Reggie I don't
know what that means but how quite like
how it this could be a mythic thing a
giant thing but it's then talking about
pancakes yeah you ate my breakfast yeah
I did
it almost should be the close quote
rather than Carson McCullers
and then we see the you know that the
Mariner and [ __ ] Miami loose just had
the black panel which the shrunk to fit
in it's not like that black good that
black panels being the same size and
every issue hasn't it it's always been
yeah and they've shrunk it the [ __ ] up
the grid the [ __ ] up the nine panel
grid it's ten panel it's ten it's the
first ever Watchmen page that's broken
in attend panels they ruined it we saw
the lock pick
we knew they're gonna get out like you
know it's it's a comic book things have
to move forward we didn't need to see
the handcuffs no need to see them that's
doing even if they are oh who cares
yeah yeah who cares the Batman could
track them down in probably about ten
minutes and get stopped yeah and we you
know
we are homesick mode for the places we
have never known it's not that deep of a
quote really but you know it's there it
just seems really random yeah it just
seems that Google's nice style shirt and
that's one of the quotes that came up I
agree I agree yeah like I'm brainy quote
where you can literally tag quotes for
whatever fee may go on he's probably
just read that and then in are kind of
you know addendums we get some you know
web pages here which I kind of like it
just from an inventive point of view
that on the second panic page we get the
Superman story and we get the news story
which is just it sort of dragged over
the top of the other story which is how
you would sort of read a web page which
is nice but essentially it's all about
this metahuman stuff how you know all
the super humans are essentially
concentrated in the u.s. what does this
mean like I don't I don't mind the story
but I just it's kind of a lame truth if
that's true if all superheroes are like
government funded and sponsored it kind
of Rob's it a lot of its magic for me
yeah to be honest I didn't really pay
much attention in these it annoyed me
more because it looks like an it's an
iPad screen yet they've got different
windows open floating about so that just
annoyed is right right right
so just slammed it slammed the entire
book off that thing alone yeah but yeah
you know kind of read bits of it and the
scene we focus very heavily on this
Superman theory which I don't know how
it's gonna play out but at the moment it
doesn't feel like it needs to be in the
book no no there's I believe as an
allusion to green lantern because basic
picture yeah on bizarre green fire
I don't like greedy's in quotation marks
destroys all American steel factory
which again do you have to call it an
All American steel factory like they
wouldn't call it that but whatever and
yeah this is clearly gonna form the
backbone of a lot of this issue and also
just there was an interview with John's
and he's got a lot about this and saying
that it's gonna you know it's big for
the universe as a whole not just
Doomsday Clock it's kind of Civil War
esque to a certain extent it's kind of
divided between and government-sponsored
and stuff like that but yeah
yeah we we this is kind of how we end
and I mean all in all death what you
fought son issue too
it's better but still it's not what I
want no do it how I want it do it
exactly the same as the last one I just
the thing is I don't want it to sound
like haters I think about how much way
Watchmen episodes you know we love that
comic and we go you know we praise it
constantly but you look at the reviews
of people people are going mad for this
issue and I'm yeah it's not good
hi Jen give it a 9 out of 10 and they
give it
The [ __ ] alien isolation like a 5 out of
10
right it's the best game ever made I
just want to say that but yeah they
don't I don't know why this is getting a
9 like what what were what was in here
that deserves that's cool
to be fair I have reviewed some books
myself that have given 9 out of 10 that
when I posted the review people have
just called as a [ __ ]
and said it was the worst comic book
story ever made ironically one of them
was actually by Geoff Johns which was
Trinity war which everyone hates but
yeah it's not it's not like I would
probably if I had score it because
everyone loves score and a 5 Cohen on a
6-5 governesses I'm gonna go over free
over 100 oh I just didn't find this
exciting to read I was reading it
because obviously we do it for the show
and I enjoy doing it for that reason and
also as a watchman fan I'm sort of
morbidly curious but it's just I didn't
think there's any pacing to it I thought
it was a lot of look at these characters
you know from different worlds meeting
but it wasn't you didn't just have the
integrity of a great plot going for it
which just didn't work for me it's to be
honest I was surprised that they had the
characters meet this early on yeah I
thought they were gonna drag it out for
like like a Frank Miller story all gonna
drag out for like 7 issues and then
they'd meet so I'm glad that they did
meet
but mm-hmm well I mean regardless kind
of bland it is kind of blunt it is kind
of bland it's kind of broad definitely
you know Laxus subtlety for me the tone
is a bit you know just bit confusing at
times on some of the paneling I thought
was rushed and didn't make it clear but
yet we will end as we always end of
course we will be back next month as
well what to do issue-free
but we end as will resume with emails we
love to hear from you please comment on
the YouTube videos as well of course and
get in touch with us watching The
Watchmen pod at gmail comm our first
email comes from David he says hi guys
wow this is the these emails I should
say came after our doomsday one review
says hi guys thank you for deciding to
cover this watchman sequel slash fan
fiction hybrid on the show but seriously
how many comets can be like peanuts or
for better or for worse the either of
definitive endings or literally got
decree by the creator that no one
continued writing about now I don't know
about for better or for worse and I'm
not reading read peanuts myself but I'll
tell you all in a David but yeah you're
right I mean you know Allen more
conclusively has said this is done I
don't if he said that impressed but
clearly that's what he thinks but you
know it goes on about the question David
says regarding if World War two
happening to Watchmen universe the
superheroes debated whether to enter the
war against the Nazis Sally rebuffed
allegations that she could possibly
polish comedian ended up fighting the
Japs in the Pacific there were many
mentions of the global nuclear war as
World War II so clearly did happen also
world war two has extensively talked
about in the suppository book pages for
book four ironically the ones you guys
pretty much skipped over because it
didn't contribute much the story good
point Dave and it says take care David
thank you very much and I mentioned
before also Fred of the show I've been
emailing just going quite a bit she had
to Eric he says thanks for the quick
follow-up
you both absolutely did not come across
harsh at all because I basically said we
came across as misers on doomsday one
you were very fair-minded you measure
John's and we tried to achieve good
research on my marionette I had no idea
of their heritage they are also maybe
even getting to pop in attack and bezzie
sorry should say at the end he attached
his photographic review of issue one and
it's a picture of the watchman balloon
deflated so no I think I think that's
very good cheers and keep up the good
work Eric so yeah everyone please get in
touch with us again
watching watchman pod at gmail.com any
closing forward Steph
yeah before commencing please don't make
any more Watchmen after this please let
you do it I'll let you do your ten more
issues but these nothing more please it
would never ever happen because I know
more would rather [ __ ] die than work
for them but wouldn't it be [ __ ]
awesome if they got more back for an
issue like they were like it's a shame
that he doesn't own the rights of those
characters why doesn't he just do his
own book cuz you know I think more is
probably sick of them I think he did
what he wanted to and now he's just like
yeah I wanted this was a complete story
thank you for ruining it you [ __ ]
with you [ __ ] marionette and mine
thanks a lot for introducing them and my
universe they're great characters thank
you thank you so much
[ __ ] yes
still yeah still yeah striking this dry
strangers dry over Christmas that lad
he's retiring from comic books actually
his last comic book he's gonna be the
final League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
oh great because actually just bought
the Omnibus of that I've sort of gotten
in the habit of buying comic books and
then just put them on my shelves and
they were reading them and but I've got
that oh yeah I love it once yeah I've
only read the first volume with that I
think League is brilliant I think it's
absolutely brilliant and it's just it's
what like Alan Moore so [ __ ] clever
that every character is like an old
Victorian allusion to something you know
it's just like he doesn't waste anything
or as John's can be you know a little
bit garbled perhaps but yeah this has
been watching The Watchmen you know
second issue of Doomsday Clock thank you
all for listening please comment below
what do you think of this issue I'm sure
a lot of people out there little comment
if you disagree with us here I don't
want anyone to have a different opinion
err me well if you are yeah if you want
to despise it email me you know and
we'll hear about this and I'll just
repost your comment what you want do
what you want but death your website
your patreon you know what what you
people check out well I don't see the
point mentioned in the patreon there cuz
no one [ __ ] subscribes to it but a
definition got at UK
check out my comic movie game reviews
I'm doing loads on it I'm reading
through all the Batman graphic novels
I've started reading through Marvel ones
I'm just just covering everything so if
you want to hear more of my stupid
opinion head over there definition with
two FS with two FS I can't spell I know
it's only got one F in normally please
don't hate me
check out Unitas a Tom Cech yeah I want
to say people check out des links you
know check out deafspace
well I've just wasted ten minutes doing
that give some me your own opinion well
what's your closing thought my closing
for I thought it was terrible
to be honest I really didn't enjoy it I
like talking about it I like trashing it
you've been reading too much alan moore
yes the problem too much good stuff
i need to read some more charity war and
i think of whole day as an incredible a
great piece of work um yeah yeah again
you know get in touch with us as well if
you're interested in battle rap me and
def have done loads of stuff on batter
up a batter out resume which my other
podcast also pakistan metallica
alphabet' a locker where i go through
all the songs the band in order with
guests from around the world check that
we'll put the links down below but yet
the best thing is for you guys to get in
touch we love to hear from you we love
the long-form correspondence on the
watchman myth files on the comics on the
feedback and yet death as always it's
been great man thank you bro
yeah that's a good name from me it's a
good night from alan moore easy there
I'm using the issue as toilet paper
get off money it's a digital copy don't
might be asked with the iPad a [ __ ]
pal
[Music]